Listening to radio lab radio from
W. N Y. S. E. N. D. O. N. P. R.
Okay. Let's see. Hello? Hello. Hi,
is this Errol Morris? I think it's
me. Hello. This is Chad from, uh,
from radio lab. Hi. Thank
you for your very, very nice,
somewhat disturbing email.
What disturbed you in the
email? The term truth fascist?
No,
you called Aaron. Laura. The Truth
Fascist, right? Were we thinking I was,
I was trying to,
I wrote them an email to try and get him
to come talk to us and I don't know why
I use that is a truth fascist
that was meant lovingly,
I should say. Aww. Wasn't exactly the
right choice of words. Fundamentalists.
Oh, I like it. But really
what I meant is it like,
this is a guy who's always trying
to get to the bottom of things.
It's made all these documentaries a thin
blue line while you got a guy off death
row, actually in a thin blue line, he
made the fog of war in Vernon, Florida.
But I contacted him because you know,
I'd recently seen him give this talk
about this one investigation of his.
The for me is like the purest
example of the thing that drives him,
think it's in all of his films,
desire, relentless desire
to figure things out,
to get to truth.
And it all starts with a photograph.
One of the very, very
first photographs of war,
1855 which war?
This is the Crimean war
that involved Great Britain,
France, Russia, the Ottoman Empire,
and believe it or not, Sardinia,
the fighting took place in what
is now basically the Ukraine.
The Russians were on one side.
Everybody else on the other
half a million people died.
It was incredibly brutal.
And there's this photograph titled
The Valley of the shadow of death.
It's black and white.
It shows a dirt road cutting
through this landscape.
Just one
Derek road
between two hills. There's nobody in
the photograph, no birds, no trees,
no people. There's really nothing living
in the photograph, not even grass,
nothing.
But as you stare at this
road a little more closely,
you realize why nothing is
living in this photograph.
Because this road is littered with Canon
cannonballs everywhere.
As soon as you notice them
photographs springs to life,
you imagine this fuselage,
artillery fire raining
down on this landscape.
This is one really fascinating thing
about photography. It's a time machine.
There's a physical connection between
that photograph and that world
cause you're holding this piece of film
that was literally ripped right out of
that world. But the context is God.
And more importantly in this case,
you don't even know if
that picture is true.
What do you mean?
It turns out that this
photograph is one of a pair.
There is a second photograph exactly
the same as the first photograph,
exact same camera position,
but in this other photograph,
the cannon balls that
were on the road are gone.
So one has cannonballs on the road and
one has cannon balls not on the road,
but otherwise they're completely
identical. Yes. He thought that's weird.
Let me look into that.
And there was a passage in any ends up
reading this essay by a Susan Sontag
where she talks about these
photographs as though it's just obvious
what was going on. And he was
like, oh, that word. Well,
I don't like the word obvious.
Susan Sontag was basically arguing
that the guy who took the picture,
Roger Fenton, came to an empty road,
put the cannonballs on the road.
He staged it. Yes, it's
obvious, but that works.
Nothing's so obvious that it's obvious.
And so I started investigating
[inaudible]
and so began a ludicrous obsessive it,
but kind of sublime pursuit
of this slippery little
fact that actually inspired
this whole hour. So today on radio lab,
we are going to wrestle with a series of
seemingly simple facts that turn out to
raise complicated questions
like what is truth?
Is it just a pile of facts and how much
does the factor that matter matter?
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, back to Errol Morris.
I tracked down Fenton's letters
from the Crimea journals,
written records of soldiers who were
in that area at that given time,
didn't find much.
I interviewed five historians who
ordered the photograph in one way
saying yes, it's obvious he posted the
pictures. This is a bit of a surprise.
Order the photographs in
the opposite way. Really,
they told them it is actually very
possible that Fenton saw the cannonballs,
took the picture, and
then soldiers came along,
took the cannibals off the road to recycle
them so they could fire them back at
the rushes. Exactly. Was that
kind of recycling common practice?
Yes, indeed. It was actually.
So you had a tie to historian saying
you faked it to saying he didn't.
And the fifth tie breaker
jump back and forth.
I like that you call it, tried
to call them the tie breaker.
They didn't break the
tie. Well, of course,
none of none of these
things is subject of a vote.
Truth isn't something that you vote on
at this point. He says he was feeling
a very familiar irritation. Start.
You know what? Forget
historical interpretations.
What if I could, from
the photograph itself,
the very photograph itself determine
which photograph came first from just the
photo. So I started a
being the photograph,
just sort of superimposing them on
each other and flipping back and forth.
A, B, B, a, B, B, a,
etc. Etc. Nothing in anything.
I know what I can do.
I can start studying the
shadows, which meant, yeah,
let's go to the Crimea. Are you serious?
Yeah.
His reasoning was I can't study the
shadows unless I knew the exact direction
the camera was pointing on that day in
1855 which means I need to find the exact
spot where Fenton stood
and I had terrible trouble finding
this place. Is it marked? No.
All the guides kept taking me to
the charge of the light brigade.
That site where Tennyson wrote about
the valley of death. No, no, no, no, no.
Not The valley of death.
The Valley of the shadow,
but finally a guide named
Olga. She was fabulous.
Helps them locate this spot. It's
completely desolate, undeveloped,
still after 150 years
with some trial and error,
he's able to figure out that Fenton was
facing north when he took those photos
and then he goes off to the
Crimean war museum and asks them,
could I borrow some cannon balls? Oh Man.
I take the cannon ball, take it out
to the valley of the shadow of death,
and I photograph it
at different times of the day,
hoping that he'd be able to see subtle
differences in the shadows cast by those
cannonballs that could
help them order the photos,
but nothing, nothing.
There was endless questions
about cloud cover,
whether you could even measure
the shadows on these photographs.
In fact,
he now suspects that the shadows in those
old pictures may not have been shadows
at all,
but just artifacts of how the
prints were made and on and on.
So was the trip useful at all? Not so much
bad. How many,
how many days did you spend photographing
and examining the photographs of
cannonballs on the road? I
was there for about a week
and then he went home with no answer
to his question, only that continuing
irritation, but he was like,
no, no, not done yet. Look,
when you investigate anything,
I don't care what it is,
whether it's a fen photograph or Abu
Ghraib or the murder of a Dallas police
officer. Yes. Complications,
result thinking causes
complications. I'm sorry,
but it's part of that process that we go
through of trying to figure out what's
out there in the world.
What really happened.
Uh,
this is about truth, absolute truth,
and
the pursuit of truth properly considered
shouldn't stop short of [inaudible]
sanity. So yes,
the Fenton photographs worried me that
I might not be able to resolve it to my
satisfaction,
but then
he said a party and he
bumps into a friend of his,
a guy by the name of Dennis Purcell,
who is very, very good with Photoshop.
We called them up. Hello? Turns
out, well, I'm an optical engineer,
so he's not just good
at Photoshop. He acts,
he builds high tech
cameras in any case, okay.
They were talking at this party
and the Fenton picture came up.
Ariel told him he had this problem of
wondering which came first and said,
could you take a look at these?
Dennis takes the pictures home,
puts them in his computer
and I immediately started
to compare them right away.
He starts noticing differences
between the two. The light changed.
The weather was different shadows,
but he comes to pretty much the same
conclusion as Arrow that those things
ultimately don't help. So he just
starts flipping between the photos,
flipping live back and forth,
back and forth between the two photograph
on the road, flip off the road,
flip on the road, flip off the road,
flips doing this for hours off the road,
flip on the road, and then he sees it.
The rocks on the left hand side,
this little group of
pebbles up on the left bank.
Every time you flip back and forth, flip,
flip, those little rocks popped out.
They moved just a little
bit and when he zoomed in,
he could see that there were five
of them. Fred, George Oswald,
Lionel and Marmaduke, we named them. Yes,
these five guys shifted
from one photo to the next.
And here's the key in the
picture where the road was empty,
they were a little bit higher on the
hill when the road was full of cannibals.
This little rock shift down maybe
eight inches or nine inches,
and from the direction of that movement,
you can order the photographs.
It's basically like this.
You could say some rocks
fell down the hill.
They went from up on the hill
to down, up goes before down.
And if the up photo is the empty road
and the down photo is the road full of
cannonballs.
Well then the one with the cannon balls
on the road was the second picture.
Imagine the scene, Fenton
comes upon an empty road.
He sees cannon balls on
the hill, so he [inaudible]
whoever was helping him would have walked
along the sides of the road and lifted
up cannonballs move them on
to the road. In that process,
they would have invariably
knocked into rocks
and rocks don't fall up hill. They
only fall downhill. It's gravity.
So case closed. This is, this has been,
yeah.
Susan Sontag was right for the
wrong reasons, but she was right.
Fenton stage the photograph.
So in addition to being one of
the first photographs of war,
this is one of the
first photographic lies.
I guess he just figured it
was a better photo. Yeah.
Or You could say Fitton was a coward.
No,
maybe he didn't want to get too
close to the actual fighting,
so he put the cannon balls on the road
to make it look a lot more dangerous than
it would have otherwise, or maybe he
was after some kind of emotional truth.
That's what Dennis Purcell thinks.
It's obvious why he did it.
There's that word again to make it look
the way it felt to put those cannonballs
on the road is how you
felt when you were there.
Which case he would argue
that the second photo,
the one he posed is more
authentic than the first.
Forget all of that. Who in hell
knows what Fenton was thinking?
I really don't know
what his motivation was,
but isn't that kind of the
question at the end of the day,
do I really care whether he put the
cannonballs on the road or not? Well,
I hope you do. If you do, don't you?
Okay.
I do and I don't really, we didn't. W
why would you go through all this then?
I guess this is what I take from it.
Mm.
In flipping back and forth between
those two photographs. Flip, he says,
you see the rocks move, flip, and
when you see the rocks move flip,
you imagine feet kicking those rocks
and when you imagine feet kicking those
rocks flip,
you feel flip the soldiers walking
like really feel it. You feel
them hitting into the rocks.
You feel on some deep sense for me,
the reality of that scene in a way
that I would not have felt otherwise.
[inaudible]
it's almost as if you've walked
through a pinhole camera into the past.
That world in which the photograph,
that strange temporal evanescent
world in which we live is gone.
But if you could step
between these photographs,
you're permitted, a brief trespass into
something that you thought was lost.
Yes.
My father died when I was two years old
and perhaps the deepest one of
the deepest mysteries of my life.
Who Waze air,
all these photographs around the house.
I was very, very young. I
have no memories of him.
There's a mystery
about this man who is central
to my life in so many ways,
but who I don't know
and who I never will know.
[inaudible]
Aaron Morris, his latest book
is called wilderness of error.
This story was taken from
his book believing is seeing,
and I also want to thank IRA glass
for helping us to connect with them.
Radio lab will continue in a moment.